mariah quiere comprar un auto nuevo el
vendedor de autos le dice que el auto
que ella quiere tiene un consumo
estimado de gasolina de 24 kilómetros
por galón el auto tiene un tanque de 12
galones maría le dice a su amiga que el
auto recorrerá exactamente 288
kilómetros con un tanque lleno esta
afirmación es razonable o no porque sí o
porque no los invito a qué pausa en el
vídeo y analicen cada una de las
opciones con cuidado ahora veamos cada
una de ellas
la primera opción si la justificación es
que el auto puede viajar exactamente 24
kilómetros por galón por 12 galones del
tanque igual a 288 kilómetros con un
tanque la matemática se ve bien ya que
estos galones ya que estos galones se
van con estos de acá y nos quedan las
unidades de kilómetros 24 por 12 288 la
matemática aquí luce bien pero esta
afirmación que ella hace de que el autor
recorre era exactamente 288 kilómetros
con un tanque lleno en esta afirmación
ella asume que el auto exactamente 24
kilómetros por galón lo que es muy
diferente a lo que nos dice el vendedor
que esto tiene un consumo estimado de
gasolina no es un consumo exacto el
estimado pudo ser un redondeo de cuando
el auto fue probado pudo haber llegado a
23.6 kilómetros por galón o incluso a
24.4 kilómetros por galón los cuales son
una gran diferencia por lo que no
tendremos exactamente 288 kilómetros
otra cosa es que esté estimado pudo
salir de promediar muchos viajes de
muchos kilómetros en diferentes
condiciones por ejemplo sus a menos
gasolina si se viaja cuesta abajo o en
una autopista se usa más gasolina cuando
estamos en el tráfico o si vamos cuesta
arriba o si vamos contra un viento más
fuerte así que no podemos asegurar que
se puede recorrer exactamente 288
kilómetros sin saber exactamente cómo se
tomó esta medida el octanaje del
combustible también será un poco
diferente por eso es difícil afirmar que
se viajará exactamente 24 kilómetros por
galón
solo dio un estimado así que esta no es
opción ve si el consumo estimado de
gasolina puede usarse para calcular la
distancia exacta que puede viajar el
auto con un tanque lleno ya mencionamos
que esto es un estimado es un aproximado
de lo que el auto puede viajar con un
tanque pero no da la distancia exacta
así que la opción ve tampoco es opción
si no 24 kilómetros por galón es un
estimado un redondeo al entero más
cercano por lo que no es razonable
tratar de calcular la distancia exacta
que puede recorrer el auto justo lo que
hemos venido diciendo es un estimado que
probablemente es un redondeo y no es
razonable usarlo para calcular
distancias exactas de no la distancia
que el auto recorre se calcula
dividiendo 24 kilómetros entre 12
galones 24 entre 12 que era exactamente
21 288
esta es la peor respuesta de todas todo
esto está mal así que la respuesta
correcta es c